شكرا لخالد ومشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون
عزام واحييكم ونكمل هذه التغطيه المستمره
حول التطورات في السودان بشكل تدريجي بدا
الهدوء يعود الى العاصمه الخرطوم وان كانت
لا تزال الاشتباكات تندلع من وقت لاخر
فبالرغم من فشل هدنه الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الا ان الامور بدات تركن الى الهدوء قليلا
رغم تبادل الطرفين الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه
وايضا التسبب في تفاقم الوضع الانساني
طبعا تحدثنا عن العاصمه الخرطوم في مروي
تحديدا شماليه السودان تمكن فريق العربيه
من الدخول وايضا التجول ظهر اليوم بمطار
مروي الدولي والقاعده الجويه العسكريه
الملحقه بالمطار صور للعربيه اظهرت حجم
الضرر الذي لحق بالبنى التحتيه للمطار
طبعا فضلا عن تدمير جزء كبير من برج
المراقبه بالمطار في وقت قال فيه الجيش
انه بات يسيطر تماما على مداخل وايضا
مخارج ومحيط القاعده والمطار دعونا نتابع
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا
المطار الذي كان مسرحا لعمليات عسكريه
خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو الان بهذه الوضعيه
وبهذه الشاكله بعد اشتداد العمليات
العسكريه والحربيه والاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه
المنطقه الان هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من
المطار هو حيوي يتعلق بهبوط بقيام
الطائرات التدريبات كانت في هذا المكان
الان القوات المسلحه السودانيه تنتشر في
محيط وفي ارجاء هذا المكان تتمركز في
مختلف الاتجاهات في الاتجاه الشمالي في
الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي الاتجاه الغربي وفي
الاتجاه الشرقي حسب افادات خاصه للعربيه
والحدث بان الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
السوداني الان تفرز سيطرتها بالكامل على
كل مداخل ومخارج هذا المطار والقاعده
العملاتيه الجويه هنا في مدينه مروي شمال
السودان يوم الامس دارت اشتباكات عنيفه
على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره تعاملت
الطيران او تعامل الطيران الجيش السوداني
مع من خرج من هذه القاعده وكبدهم خسائر
فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر عسكريه الان هذا
المطار بكلياته بكامله في يد الجيش
السوداني ويد القوات المسلحه من داخل مطار
مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده العسكريه
الجويه العملياتيه نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
ونزار بقداوي ينضم الينا الان مباشره من
مدينه مروي اهلا بك نزار بعد ان شاهدنا
الصور من داخل المطار اعطينا اي معلومات
حصلت عليها من مشاهدات من كانوا هناك من
حدث وكان يحدث خلال الخمسه ايام الماضيه
وعندما نتحدث عن خسائر كبيره
بعد تعامل الطيران الحربي مع من خرج من
المطار هل لدينا تفاصيل اوفى عمان نجا عن
حجم الضحايا وتقييم الخسائر اذا مصحه
التعبير بصوره عامه نزار
نعم تقريبا الخطايا المرحله التي
بدات الان هنا في القاعده الجويه وفي
المطار مرحله تقييم الاضرار او الخسائر
واجلاء من تعرضوا للقتل وللاصابه وللضرر
خلال هذه العمليه العسكريه التي استمرت
لاربعه ايام ندرك ان الامور كانت معقده
وكانت ملتبسه وكانت متشابكه في اجزاء
متباعده لهذا المطار وهذه القاعده التي
تمتد لنحو 18 كيلو متر مربع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه كانت تتمركز في
اكثر من موقع واكثر من محور الان القوات
المسلحه بدات في تمشيط محيط المطار
لمعرفه اوضاع الجنود الذين كانوا في تلك
المناطق لمعرفه وضعيتهم ان كانوا مصابين
او غير ذلك ايضا تمشيط المناطق التي كانت
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع تفتيش
الاليات التي تركت من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع
لاحظنا ايضا خلال تجوالنا قبل قليل في هذه
القاعده حجم الضرر الذي
تم ببرج المراقبه الرئيس للمطار والقاعده
هنالك طائرات ايضا تعرضت طائرات المدنيه
وطائرات عسكريه ايضا تضررت
هذه العمليات العسكريه والاشتباكات
المسلحه ايضا هنالك سيارات تتبع لقوه
الدفاع المدني كانت تقدم خدماتها للطائرات
التي تهبط في هذا المطار ايضا تضررت بشكل
جزئي علمنا ايضا من مدير مطار مروي الدولي
بان هذا المطار كان على بعد خطوات قليله
من ان يدخل مرحله جديده وفق التصنيفات
الدوليه للملاحه الجويه والطيران المدني
لكن الاشتباكات التي حدثت والضرر الذي حدث
قد يعيق من ان يمضي مطار مروي نحو اهدافه
الموضوعات سالنا ايضا عن
هي المده الزمنيه التي تحتاجها القاعده
والمطار حتى اليهود الى مكان للجواب
مباشره كان بان المرحله الحاليه هي مرحله
التقييم الاضرار تقييم ما حدث وبعده يرفع
التقرير لمعرفه المدى الزمني وما يحتاجه
المطار من امكانيات ماديه ولوجستيه وفنيه
حتى يعود ليباشر عمله من جديد واي معلومات
عن من خرج من قوات الدعم السريع مصيرهم هل
تم القاء القبض على بعض منهم الاستهدافات
من قبل الطيران ما الذي ادت اليه
هنالك عناصر تتبع للدعم السريع الان هي في
يد القوات المسلحه السودانيه بعد العمليات
التي حدثت خلال اليومين الماضيين
بقيه القوه التي كانت تتمركز داخل مطار
مروي والقاعده خرجت مساء امس وعصر امس
بالاتجاه الجنوبي صوب العاصمه الخرطوم وقد
تعاملت معها القوات الجويه في طلعات ادت
الى خسائر كبيره في صفوف الدعم السريع
بحسب تصريحات لقاده الجيش هذا هو الوضع
وهذا هو الواقع المواطنون الان
بداوا يتنسمون مزيدا من الاريحيه انجاز
التعبير وبدات تدب الحياه من جديد في
مدينه مروي ولكن بشكل نسبي السوق الكبير
الذي يمثل المركز التجاري الاكبر بعض
المحاله التجاريه بدات تعاود نشاطها
الطرقات الان الحركه فيها سالكه قوات
الجيش تتمركز في بعض النقاط تعمل على
تفتيش الماره خاصه الذين يرتادون السيارات
لمعرفه الهويه في اطار تدقيق امني
ومعلوماتي حسب ما فهمنا لان المنطقه ايضا
ما زالت في اطار الحرب باعتبار ان العمليه
العسكريه مستمره في عدد من مدن السودان
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن يومين حتى العيد
الناس يبدو انهم غير معنيين بهذه اللحظه
بتجهيز لذلك ولا هنا ليس هناك حتى من
امكانيه لذلك
يعني هنالك ملامح
لبعض الاسر التي رايناها تتجول في السوق
سالنا هل
ما يتيح هل في النفس متسع لفرحه بعيد هل
بامكان المواطنين الان ان يعدوا العده
للدخول في فرحه العيد اجابوا بصوره مختصره
بان العيد فرحه وعليه ان يفرحوا وهم يعدون
لذلك الاوضاع يقولون بانها انجلت ويتوقعون
ان تمضي نحو الافضل لا يتوقعون الاسوا
ويطالبون القوات المسلحه بفرض مزيد من
السيطره على كل الارجاء المحيطه بالمطار
وبالمدينه وهل من تصريحات رسميه خرجت
بعيدا عن البيان الذي ذكرته خلال عرض
تقريرك عن داخل او ما يحدث ان كان في
القاعده او في المطار
والسيطره الكامله نقل فكره السيطره
الكامله للجيش الان على هذه المنطقه هل من
تصريحات اخرى ان كان من الرد السريع او من
غيره من الجهات فيما يتعلق بهذه الازمه
بصوره عامه
هذه المرحله التي دخلتها العمليه العسكريه
التي بدات قبل خمسه ايام
هي مرحله هي عمليه تمتد وتتقلص كر وفر هي
عمليه مستمره حتى الان البيانات الرسميه
والبيانات النهائيه قد تاخذ بعض الوقت الى
ان تنجلي الامور لكن ما يعرف وما يؤكد
عليه هنا في مروي بان الجيش له من
الامكانيات كما يقول قادته
لبسط السيطره لبسط فرض الهيبه للتحرك في
كل المسارات التي تستدعي التحرك بحكم وجود
اليات ووحدات مختلفه تتمركز هنا في
الولايه الشماليه ذكرت بالبدايه انه الان
فتره عمليه التنشيط وتقييم الاضرار ولكن
هل تلمست ان هناك نوع من المخاوف ان تكون
هناك عوده ربما لقوات الدعم السريعه او لا
امكانيه الان
هذه الاشاره وهذه الفرديه يتخوف منها
المواطنون عندما تنقل كتساؤل وكسؤال يطرح
للقوات النظاميه هنا الجيش يقول بانه في
حاله حرب وحاله الحرب تعني التمركز
والانتشار واعاده التمدد هذا ايضا يعني
بان الجيش يتحسب لكل مرحله بظرفيه معينه
قد تاتي قوات الدعم السريع قد تشترك مره
اخرى ولكن الان لا حديث عن هذه العوده
الحديث كله الان ينصب عن تهيئه الظروف
والاوضاع لبسط السيطره في اكبر نسبه ممكنه
من هذه المحليه محليه مروي والحديث بعدها
عن ان المنطقه الان اصبحت بكاملها تحت
سيطره ونفوض القوات المسلحه السودانيه من
مدينه مروي مراسل عربيه نزار بقداوي شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
هذا هو يواصل الطرفان تاكيد تحقيق مكاسب
على الارض نشر الجيش السوداني مقاطع فيديو
تؤكد احراز تقدم في الخرطوم دعونا ونتابع
[موسيقى]
ومن جانبها نشرت قوات الدعم السريع صورا
تظهر استهداف دبابات الجيش السوداني داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا نتابع
الله اكبر هذه الذبابه امامكم
الله اكبر مباشر مباشر
المزيد معنا من جنوب الخرطوم الصحفي مدثر
محمد احمد اهلا بك بدايه اي معلومات
متوفره لديك حول التطورات على الارض هل
يمكن القول الان انه
ربما الهدوء هو سيد الموقف ام ماذا
منطقه تقريبا انا الان في منطقه سوبا
شوبا غرب وهي الان بجوار ما يعرف بكوبري
سوبا هنا في منطقه توبه او منطقه جنوب الخ
رطوم واستغلالا لهذه الهدنه هناك عشرات او
مئات الرحلات التي
انطلقت من الخرطوم من العائلات والاسر نحو
مناطق ولايات الجزيره وغيرها من الولايات
المنتخبه للخرطوم حيث
استطاعوا تمكن العديد من الاسر والمواطنين
من الخروج من ولايه الخرطوم الى الولايات
الاخرى انا الان في منطقه كوفا اشاهد منذ
ساعه او منذ اكثر من ساعتين
مرور المئات من العربات سواء العربات
الخاصه
والشاحنات او
عربات النقل او الحافلات السفريه التي
تنقل المواطنين من ولايه الخرطوم او من من
مختلف مدن الولايات الخرطوم الى خارج ولاد
الخرطوم منطقه كوبري سوبا كانت بالامس
منطقه احداث حيث شهدت قصف جويا
الذي كانت قد تمركزت في منطقه
شرط في منطقه سوبا شرق وتعاملت معها قوات
القوات المسلحه عبر القصف الجوي ولكن
اليوم لم نشرب اي اشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
منذ مساء الارض كانت التركيز الان في تلك
المنطقه تحديدا حول خروج مجموعات من الناس
لا اعلم ان كان يمكن ان نسميه نزوح داخلي
الان الى المناطق الامنه اعود اليك سيد
مدثر ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل الى الخرطوم
بحري من هناك ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه لينقل لنا الوضع هناك من حيث هو تفضل
الو ايوه اخ عمار
مرحبا ميسون واهلا بمشاهدين الكرام اهلا
وسهلا كنا نتحدث مع ضيفي مده حول الوضع من
حيث هو في جنوب السودان واردت ان اعرف
مشاهداتك عما يحدث حيث انت
طبعا في مدينه بحري هنالك مناطق بالغه
الحساسيه والاشتباك خاصه فيما يخص المناطق
الجنوبيه جنوب احياء بحري المطله على
النيل الازرق وعلى الخرطوم العاصمه من
الناحيه الجنوبيه حيث يوجد الجسر وجسر
النيل الازرق وايضا المطله على مناطق ام
درمان
الاخرى الغربيه من الجانب الاخر المدينه
في هذا الصباح يعني كانت هنالك عديد من
الطائرات التي تقصف مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريعه المتواجده في المدينه في اقصى
المنطقه الغربيه وفي اقصى المنطقه الشرقيه
تتواجد عديد من القوات لدعم السريع كان
هنالك قصف جوي الان قبل قليل تتحرك عدد من
الطائرات المسيره
وترد عليها المضادات الارضيه بكثافه ربما
انا اسمع صوت الان فيما يخص مناطق شرق
بحري هنالك موجه نزوح وخروج لعدد من الاسر
والعائلات الان داخل احياء البحري خاصه
الشماليه وهنالك موقف شندي الذي ربما يعمل
بشكل حذر نوعا ما تخرج الاسر وهنالك بساط
سفريه للسفريات الداخليه تتحرك باتجاه
الخروج نحو المنطقه الشماليه من مدينه
بحري هنالك ايضا ازمات اخرى تعاني منها
المدينه يعني كافه ارجاء المدينه بشكل
كبير انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ما بين فتره
واخرى وهنالك ايضا
شحال المياه وهذه هي المشكله الاكبر الان
التي يعاني منها السكان حيث لجاوا للابار
ولجاوا الى عبيد من المناطق التي ربما
يكون فيها مناطق اشتباكات خاصه على
المنطقه الصناعيه بحري هنالك تواجد لقوات
الدعم السريع وهنالك ايضا يعني قوات من
الجيش تتحرك بين الفين والاخرى وعدد
طائرات التي ذكرت بانها الان بحسب
مشاهداتك
في الاجواء وكانت قد استهدفت بعض المناطق
التي يتحصن فيها الدعم السريع او تتحسن
فيها قوات الدعم السريع وهنا سؤالي يتعلق
في حجم انتشار قوات الدعم السريعه على
الارض ام انها في مراكزها الخاصه
هذه القوات تتحرك في في خطوط معينه يعني
داخل
معسكرات لها في معسكر كافوري ومعسكر
المظلات على الجانب الغربي وعلى الجانب
الشرقي وهنالك ايضا جسر كوبر في المنطقه
الاخرى وهنالك منطقه كافوري التي يتواجد
بها عدد من القوات حتى الان ليست هنالك
مشاهدات فعليه او ارقام محدده لعدد من
السيارات
وما فيها ولكن نلاحظ خاصه ليلا يعني كميه
وحجم المضادات الارضيه التي ترد على عمليه
الطيران الحربي الذي ياتي بين الفين
والاخرى يعني تسكت هذه المضادات وهي تتحرك
مره اخرى باتجاه السماء وما فيها من
طائرات حربيه وبمع يمكن القول انه في بحري
على الاقل من حيث انت في الشرق الهدنه لم
تزر هذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه اسمح لي
ان انتقل الى
ضيفي طبعا من جنوب الخرطوم والدسر مده كنت
تتحدث عن عمليه نزوح للناس الى مناطق امنه
طبيعه المناطق الامنه التي يمكن ان يذهبوا
اليها والخروج من تلك المنطقه هو خوفا من
عوده المعارك ام انه لا الموضوع هو
الاحتياجات طبيعيه للناس في ظل الوضع
الماساوي ان كان فيما يتعلق بالكهرباء او
فيما يتعلق بالمياه وغيره
نعم هو كلما ذكرته هو هي من اسباب موجه
هذا اللجوء المعلوم ان بغير هذه الاحداث
هناك هذه المناسبه العيد تكون فيها عمليه
خروج من العاصمه الخرطوم او من ولاد
الخرطوم نحو الولايات لحضور مناسبه العيد
في الولايات ولكن مع هذه الاحداث
يعني تضاعفت هذه الحوجه من الخروج لمجرد
الخروج
لحدود مناسبه العيد
الفقدان الامن وفقدان المعينات الاساسيه
من من المواد الغذائيه في بعض المناطق
كذلك من حاله الرعب لدى الاطفال الذين
اصيبوا بحالات كبيره جراء العمليات القفز
في المناطق المحيطه بمنطقه الخرطوم على
على وجه الخصوص يعني مناطق بريه ومناطق
ومناطق المنشيه والرياض هذه مناطق
هي لا لا لا لم تصلها لم يصل اليها القصف
ولكن الدولي المدافع ودويه القصد
ما يثير في هذه المنطقه هناك بعض
القذائف الطائشه التي تصل او تتساقط على
هذه الاحياء بين الفين والاخرى ولكن
هم في هذه المنطقه اكثر المتضررين من هذه
من عمليه من عمليه
العسكريه التي تدور في محيط القياده
العامه ومطرح ومنطقه وسط الخطوط
محصله هل لدينا مده محصله لضحايا هذه
الاشتباكات الان نهائيه على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه او لا
حتى حتى الان لم ترد الينا احصائيات محدده
ولكن بالامس في منطقه منطقه ناصر ومنطقه
البراري كان هناك ثلاثه قتله اصيبوا
بمقذوفات فقط في المنازل القريبه لمنطقه
القياده العامه ومنطقه المطار طيب اسمحلي
حتى الان ننتقل الى
ان انتقل الى السيد عمار خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالخسائر البشريه هنا والمدنيين في ظل ما
ذكروا من انتشار للدعم السريع على الارض
واستهدافات من قبل الطيران خبرنا اكثر عن
ذلك والى اي حد بالفعل هناك نوع من فقدان
الامن على الارض يشاع بين الناس
بيسون يعني الحركه داخل الاحياء تكون بحذر
خاصه في اوقات الذروه ونحن في شهر رمضان
وخواتيم هذا الشهر المبارك وهنالك حوجه
لعديد من الاشياء التي يعني يعتمد عليها
المواطن بشكله اليومي من الغذاء والماء
وما فيها من ازمات على مستوى البقالات
والمحال التجاريه التي ايضا تعمل بحذر على
مستوى الارواح هنالك يعني
داخل الاحياء وحركه بحذر المستشفيات في
هذه المنطقه مقدسه بكثير جدا من الحالات
وهنالك اشارات ونداءات ومناشدات داخل هذه
المستشفيات بان الطاقه الاستيعابيه للاسره
والعديد من
المشافي والمراكز الصحيه في المنطقه يعني
انا بجوار مركز لقصيده الكلى هذا المركز
لا يعمل بشكل كامل هنالك نواقص في الكوادر
الطبيه المستشفيات البعيده نوعا ما
والمركزيه اصبحت ممتلئه وهنالك اصوات ضرب
القذائف من كل اتجاهات هنالك نسمع عن
وفيات نسمع عن جرحى
يعني كثير جدا من الصفحات الاعلاميه او
كثيره جدا من الصحفيين ربما وهذه تجربه
الشخصيه يعني يتنقلون في المعلومات ما بين
شهد العيان ما بين السؤال ما بين التحرك
فيما يعني يسمح لهم ذلك خاصه في المنطقه
وهذه المناطق باعتبارها مناطق حروب وخطره
جدا يعني ربما تتحرك كيلومترات وتعرف ماذا
يدور هنا وماذا يدور هناك تاتيك رسائل
تاتيك صور تاتيك مناشدات وحوجات ضروريه
ربما الخطاب الان الذي يسيطر على مساحات
كثيره جدا من السوشيال ميديا وخطاب
المناشدات والحوجات الانسانيه وربما اتجه
الكثيرون الحروب ليس فيها كاسب وليس فيها
منتصر بقدر ما فيها مساحه من الامان عندما
تقدم لشخص اخر داخل هذه المناطق
الصعبه ومناطق الحروب تقدم له خدمه
انسانيه في ان تنجد انسان او يخرج من
مناطق وهو عالق فيها يكون هنا الانتصار
الكبير بالتاكيد خاصه واننا في معركه مع
الوعي بنسبه كبيره وهذا يدفعنا للتساؤل
بالفعل عن الحراك المجتمعي على الارض
واسمح لي ان انتقل الى مدثر الحديث عن هذه
النقطه وكيفيه التعاطي مع الاحداث الان
على مستوى مجتمعي
نعم على المستوى المجتمعي هنا كما ذكرت لك
منذ البدايه ان منطقه سوبا غرب هي منطقه
تكاد تكون بعيده عن الاحداث او عن احداث
الاشتباكات ولذلك
منذ اليوم الاول الجميع هنا فتحوا منازلهم
لاقاربهم من المناطق التي تشهد اشتباكات
سواء في مناطق الخرطوم او مناطق ومن درمان
او مناطق بحري عديده الاسر وصلت الى
اهاليهم هنا في منطقه سوبا
للحصول على الامان في هذه المنطقه
هنا في هذه المنطقه بكل تاكيد كما ذكرت لك
من البدايه لم تشهد هذه المنطقه
الا بالقدر اليسير في منطقه سوبر شرق وهي
بالمنطقه الشرقيه لمنطقه شوربه غرب اي شرق
النيل من هناك من الجانب الاخر ولكن وهذا
الامان اعطى
الكثيرين
الدافع للحصول او للحضور الى منطقه سوبا
الان كنت قد تحدثت قبل قليل مع عدد من
الاسر التي وصلت عن طريق كوبري سوبا وصلت
الى منطقه سوق غرب وتتالتع عن يعني الناس
يخرجون الى خارج الخرطوم اي من اين اتيتم
قالوا نحن اتينا من منطقه الشرق النيل
منطقه الحاج يوسف
اخرون قالوا اننا اعطينا من ام درمان نحن
قادمون الى منطقه سوبا هنا لدينا اهالينا
في منطقه شعبه لدينا معارفنا في منطقه سوق
الغرب
للاحتماء بهذه المنطقه من جراء العمليات
الحربيه التي تجي في تلك في تلك المناص
هذا الامان المتوفر ولو النسبه مصحه تعبير
ما وراءه
لماذا ليس هناك من مناطق لماذا هناك
بالاحرى مناطق امنه ومناطق غير امنه
المناطق الامنه هي المناطق غير التي لا
تمثل المناطق استراتيجيه بالنسبه للقوات
العسكريه والدعم السريع او شعاع القوات
المسلحه منطقه شوربه هي منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم
ان تكون هدف للسيطره عليها هي منطقه سكنيه
بحثا ليست هناك بها مرافق حيويه ولا مشات
استراتيجيه حتى تكون هدفا للعمليات
العسكريه ولذلك
الامان بالنسبه الذين يقضون بهذه المنطقه
هذا لا يعني
ليس فقط القلق ولكن ايضا اعتقد الواقع
الاقتصادي ثقيل على الجميع اعود اليك ولكن
اسمح لي ان انتقل الى عمار لنتحدث اكثر عن
الوضع خاصه ان المنطقه عنده
متازيه فيما يتعلق بالاستهدافات والتحركات
الميدانيه على الارض عمار في ظل فقدان
الامن نحن نعلم ان هناك طرفين متصارعين
ولكن بالمقابل هناك من يعتاش على مثل هذا
الوضع هل هناك نوع من الفوضى او لا لا زال
الموضوع متصل ومرتبط مباشره بالجيش مقابل
الدعم السريع
يعني بحسب المشاهدات وبحسب كثير جدا من
الاخبار والانباء التي ترد الينا داخل
الاحياء هنالك عمليه حذر من موضوع الفوضى
هذه المنطقه خصوصا للمناطق البحري
الشماليه الشرقيه ربما تعرضت في كثير جدا
من المواقف
ايام سابقه ومواقف معروفه الى عصابات
النهب والسلب ولكن حتى الان ربما لم نشاهد
او لم نلحظ اي عمليات للفوضى هنالك حركه
للمواطنين داخل الاحياء يبتاعون ويعتاشون
ولكن بحذر شديد خاصه يعني بعد الافطار
ربما يصعب عمليه الحركه اول مواطن يحافظ
على نفسه ولا يتحرك كثيرا خاصه في الليل
مع انقطاع التيار الكهربائي مع انقطاع
للمياه هنالك ايضا عمليات يعني
التنشيط للمواطنين تبدو ظاهره ويخبرون
اذا ما كانوا هنالك اي عمليات للسلب او
عندما نتحدث عن ان المواطن السوداني يعتاش
الان لا شك انه الازمه الاقتصاديه كانت
ثقيله على
السودانيين بصوره عامه هذا قبل مثل هذه
الاشتباكات ماذا عن الوضع الان وكيف يمكن
وصفه عمار
الوضع الاقتصادي الان يمكن داخل احياء
بحري بشكل عام ووضع صعب السوق الكبير الذي
يعتمد عليه المواطنين بنسبه كبيره حرق
وتدمر فيه اجزاء بالغه وحساسه هنالك سوق
المركز الاخر الذي يقع في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه توجد فيه المناطق اشتباك
خاصه لهذا الطريق الذي يحاذ السوق
يقودها يذهب به الى موقع معسكر المظلات
الذي يتحصل فيه الدعم السريع وهنالك
اشتباكات ربما من خلال الطيران واخوات
اشتباكات ارضيه ايضا هنالك سوق صعب قشره
وهو سوق لا يبتاع منه الناس ربما الاشياء
الضروريه اليوميه من الغذاء والباء هو سوق
للاحتياجات الاخرى وما فيها من احتياجات
للمواطنين خاصه مع الاعياد لكن الوضع
الاقتصادي والمعيشي داخل الاحياء لعدد من
البقالات السوبر ماركات كبيره ربما لفدت
المياه مياه الشرب الصحيه نفذت كثير جدا
من المواسم يخص الدقيق والزيت وعديد من
المواد التي يمكن ان يعتمد عليها المواطن
بشكل اساسي في وجباته خاصه على مستوى
الافطار في شهر رمضان هل الحال نفسه فيما
يتعلق بالوضع المعيشي ايضا
من حيث انت مدثر في جنوب السودان هل
الامان يعطي دعما
معيشيا اقتصاديا للناس في تلك المنطقه ام
انه الوضع ينطبق على الجميع بغض النظر كان
هناك امان او لم يكن
بالتاكيد الامان يعطي وضعا المعيشيا افضل
خاصه وان مواطني هذه المناطق اعتادوا ان
يتحركوا بامانه ان يذهبوا الى منطقه او
الى منطقه العاصمه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
ويبت
عون جدا خاصه عندما يتوفر الاعمال تكون
هنالك وفره في كثير جدا من الخيارات
على كل من جنوب الخرطوم الصحفي مده سر
محمد احمد شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفي ايضا
من الخرطوم بحري
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه على المشاركه
[موسيقى]
هذا وراء صدى مراسل العربيه من داخل مدينه
مراوي حاله من الهدوء النسبي تشهده
المدينه المطله على مطار وقاعده مروي
الجويه العسكريه طبعا حاله الهدوء هذه بعد
ساعات قليله من اعلان الجيش السيطره
الكامله على المطار والقاعده الجويه دعونا
نتابع
نحن الان امام مدخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه هذه المدينه التي كانت شاهده على
خمسه ايام من الاشتباكات والعمليات
العسكريه كيف هي الحياه بعد خمسه ايام من
الاشتباكات سنحاول ان ندخل الى مدينه مروي
مباشره لنتعرف على تفاصيل الحياه هنا كيف
هو حال المواطنين في هذه المدينه بعد خمسه
ايام من الاشتباكات سنحاول ان نستمع الى
الصوت الحقيقي صوت المواطن في هذه المحليه
مرحبا بك الان الحمد لله زي ما شفتوها
ونحن قاعدين في مكاتبنا والسوق شغال وكل
حاجه تمام والجماهير وقفت مع الجيش وان
شاء الله كل شئ حيكون تمام وانا اطمن
اهلنا في الولايه الشماليه وفي السودان
وخاصه المغتربين بان الامن الان في مريم
وستب 100% طول الاوضاع كلها والله تحت
السيطره ما في دعم سريعه عشان والله في
المطار ولا الدعم السريع في حته الفلانيه
الدعم السريع ما عنده تواجد
كيف الاوضاع في مروي الاوضاع امنه مستغره
والمواطن مرقه سوق لشراء اغراض العيد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اذن هذا واقع الحال هنا في
مدينه مروي بالولايه الشماليه بعد خمسه
ايام من عمليات عسكريه واشتباكات مسلحه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الامور كما
تشاهدون الان في مروي تمضي نحو الهدوء
ونحو الاستقرار لقناه العربيه والحدث نزار
البغداوي من داخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه
ومشاهدينا كما نتابع على العواجل الدعم
السريع تعلن موافقتها على هدنه لمده 24
ساعه تبدا هذا المساء وتنتهي غدا في
الساعه السادسه مساء طبعا وهذه تعتبر هدنه
جديده في ظل هدنه اولى اعتبرت هشه طبعا في
ظل الاستمرار الاشتباكات وان كانت متقطعه
وان كان الهدوء قد زاد في بعض المناطق على
كل نكمل حول الوضع في الخرطوم وسائل
الاعلام سودانيه افادت ان الجيش قطعت
اتصالات الهواتف المحموله لقيادات الدعم
السريع ولحراسهم الخاص وايضا لعدد من
الضباط والجنود الصحيفه اشارت الى ان قوات
الدعم السريع فقدت في ساعات القتال الاولى
المركز الرئيسي للقياده والسيطره بعد ان
تم تدميره الاتصالات في مبنى رئاسه الدعم
السريع الذي [__] احدث شبكات الاتصالات
والتجسس
كانت قوات الدعم السريعه اتهمت الجيش
بمسؤوليته عن خرق الهدنه الاولى اضافت ان
الجيش مستمر في شن هجمات باسلحه ثقيله على
مواقع تمركز عناصرها لافته الى استمرار
الجيش في تحريك قوات عسكريه من مختلف
المدن الى الخرطوم الدعم السريع زعمت ان
طائرات حربيه للجيش قصفت تجمعات سكنيه ما
تسبب في اصابه ومقتل مدنيين وتدمير
مستشفيات
بدوره تهمل جيش قوات الدعم السريع بعدم
الالتزام ايضا قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الجيش السوداني العميد نبيل عبد الله قال
ان الدعم السريع انتهك وقفه اطلاق النار
الذي تم الاتفاق عليه بموجب وساطه دوليه
عبد الله قال ان قوات الدعم السريع لم
تتوقف عن مناوشاتها في محيط القياده وفي
مدينتي مروي والخرطوم بحري مؤكدا ان الجيش
سيواصل عملياته لتامين العاصمه والمناطق
الاخرى
الى ذلك هزا انفجار ضخم مطار الخرطوم فيما
تتواصل المعارك في احدث اشاره طبعا على
خرق الهدنه بين طرفي الصراع قال شهود
داعيان ان قديفه اصابت احد خزانات وقود
الطائرات في المطار ما ادى لتصاعد الادخنه
الكثيفه في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا في ظل اتهام كل جهه الاخرى
لخارق الهدنه الدعم السريع بحسب العواجل
تقول بانها تامل باي يلتزم الجيش الهدنه
الجديده التي وافق عليها الدعم السريع منذ
دقائق من الان واكد انها ستكون لمده 24
ساعه تبدا مساء هذا اليوم وحتى السادسه
مساء الغد على كل
هذه صور الان من العربيه من داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم تظهر الدخان يتصاعد وذلك من
العاصمه الخرطوم على كل معنى من هناك
الكاتب الصحفي عادل سيد احمد اهلا بك قبل
ان ابدا بقضيه الهدنه الجديده دعنا نتحدث
عن هذه الهدنه الهشه والتي خلقت اكثر من
مره نشاهد الدخان يتصاعد من قلب العاصمه
المعلومات لديك
نعم انا اعتقد انه الهدنه بتواجهها مشكله
اساسيه انه عدم وجود ثقه بين الطرفين في
تنفيذ الهدنه بالشكل المطلوب وبالشكل
المهني خاصه ان ان الدعم السريع انا اعتقد
انه هناك شكوك كبيره جدا من الغوادر
المسلحه حول ان الدعم السريع سيحاول
الاستفاده من فتره وقف النهر والهدنه كي
يعزز المواقفه ويعيد ترتيب اوراقه هذا
جانب هو الذي لعب
دور في في عدم تنفيذ الهدنه بل وانهيار
منذ ساعات الاولى وهذا يعطينا اشاره سيد
عادل عن مصير الهدنه الثانيه التي اعلن
عنها الدعم السريع
بالضبط انا اعتقد انه الدعم السريع
اذا توفرت
معلومات مؤكده للقوات المسلحه ان الهدنه
مقصود بها البعد الانساني فانها من الممكن
ان تنجح ولكن انا اعتقد انه لا تتوفر
معلومات مؤكده حول التزام
الدعم السريع بقواعد الهدنه لذلك لا اتوقع
ان تنجح باي شكل من الاشكال
خاصه وانه الواضح ان القوات المسلحه وهذا
الراي الفني بحث ان يتقدم في في مواقع
مختلفه في ميدان المعركه
ويستولي على هذه الاماكن بشكل ملفت بشكل
واضح ولعل التقرير الذي ورد اليك من مروي
يشير بجلاء طيب ولكن دعني اتحدث طبعا
نستمع الى
باكات لا زالت فيما يبدو مستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه وبكثافه رغم اننا نتحدث عن هدنه
على كل دعني اسالك فيما يتعلق
بالهدنه الجديده وغياب الثقه
وغياب الضمانات ما طبيعه الضمانات
المطلوبه من هو
او الجهه القادره على الحصول على ضمانات
من هو الراعي الامثل لمثل هذه الهدنه يبدو
انه الجانب الامريكي فشل
اريد ان اقول لك نقطه هامه جدا فيما يتعلق
بموضوع الخدمه
ثاني وضع عسكري او وضع حربي في الم
لان كان هناك طرف يحس بانه يحزن انتصارات
وانه اقترب من النصر النهائي
فبضروره لن تكون له مصلحه في هذه الهدنه
خاصه انه يتخوف وانه من الممكن ان تكون
الهدن على حساب انتصاراته وعلى حساب تقدمه
هذا من ناحيه القوات المسلحه من ناحيه
الدعم السريع هو يريد الهدنه حسب اعتقادي
البسيط وانا اسكن في منطقه غريبه جدا من
مناطق العمليات انا اعتقد انه الدعم
السريع يعني من خلال بعض المؤشرات
هناك ما يشير للقوات المسلحه بان الدعم
السريع يرغب في الهدنه الالتقاط انفاسه
اذا هذا الوضع انا لا اعتقد انه الهدنه
ستتم بشكل قبل قليل ولكن بالنهايه هناك
اتصالات ان كان على المستوى الاقليمي على
المستوى الداخلي او على المستوى الدولي مع
الطرفين ويبدو ان الدول في معظمها رات في
ان تكون في صف الوسط اذا مصحه تعبير وان
لا تتخذ اي موقف ان تكون حياديه بهذا
الاطار حتى تفسح المجال لامكانيه التواصل
مع
القيادات وربما الوصول الى حلوى بالتالي
لا يمكن لنا ان نلغي قضيه الاوراق التي
يمكن ان تلعبها هذه القوى الكبرى عندما
تتحدث مع هذه الاطراف وبالتالي هل من هي
الجهه القادره على تاثير ان كان على الجيش
او حتى على الدعم السريع بغض النظر عن ان
كان يريد التقاط الانفاس او فعلا هناك
حاجه انسانيه
ربما يريد من خلال هذه الهدنه ان يوفرها
صحيح انا اعتقد انه اكثر جهه اموال البعث
الدوليه التي يقودها فولكر انا اعتقد هي
مقبوله لطرفين ومن الممكن ان ان تلعب دور
في هذا الجانب هي هي الجهه المؤكد انها
مؤهله ومقبوله لطرفين مقبوله ولكن الى اي
حد هي قادره على فرض رؤيتها على الطرفين
او الوصول وامكانيه الوصول الى حل اذا
كانت الولايات المتحده لم تستطع فرض ذلك
وهنا في سؤال كبير لماذا فشلت الولايات
المتحده في ذلك هل الاطراف المعنيه غير
معنيه بدور الولايات المتحده ام ماذا
انا اعتقد انه
عدم الالتزام
بالهدنه حسب ما
وافق عليها طرفان من خلال مكالمه هاتفيه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ان لم تتحرر الهدنه الثانيه او ان لم
تلتزم الاطراف بوقف اطلاق النار فان
الخطوه الاولى التي قام بها المتحده
الامريكيه في قناع الطرفين او حتى
المحاولات المضنيه التي يقوم بها المبعوث
الخاص فولكر اعتقد انه
ان لم تتحقق الهدنه الاولى وحتى الثانيه
ربما
تكون الاخيره
وان لم ماذا
في كثير جدا من الدول بفرض شكل من اشكال
الضغوط على الاطراف كي تحملها على تنفيذ
هذه مثل ماذا شو طبيعه الضغوط التي يمكن
ان تؤثر ان كان على الدعم السريع او على
الجيش للوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار واذا
كانت هذه الاوراق موجوده لماذا لم تستخدم
حتى هذه اللحظه
ميسون هناك تمرق فيما يتعلق بالاجراءات
الدوليه سواء كان على مستوى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه المتحده في التعامل مع
مثل هذه المسالك انا اعتقد انه الخطوه
القادمه اغد تاتي من الاداره الامريكيه او
من مجلس الامن باتخاذ قرارات صارمه جدا في
هذا الجانب
وبالزام الاطراف
بالالتزام بالهدنه والا من الممكن ان يتم
اتخاذ شكل من اشكال العقوبات او شكل من
اشكال
المقاطعه او اي شكل من اشكال الضغوط لحمل
الطرفين على تنفيذهم طيب الصور التي
نشاهدها الان والنيران التي تتصاعد هي
بالقرب من مقر القياده العامه في الخرطوم
لماذا لماذا عذرا التركيز على مقر القياده
العامه ما الاستفاده من قبل الطرفين ما
الذي يمثله او تمثله السيطره الكامله على
مقر القياده العامه
طبعا القياده العامه هي قياده العمليات
على مستوى السودان توجد بها الاجهزه وتوجد
بها الادارات وتوجد بها قيادات الاسلحه
المختلفه من دبابه من سلاح مشاه
وسلاح جو وكل الادارات التي تدير العمليه
على نطاق السودان مركزه الرئيس هو القياده
العامه
ومعلوم انه في تاريخ السودان القياسي
وتاريخه العسكري انه الانقلابات مثلا تبدا
من القياده العامه اي
طرف الق
ياده على الحكم في السودان لذلك كله طرف
يحس كل طرف في الميدان يحس بانه من خلال
سيطرته على القياده عامه يستطيع ان يسيطر
على مقاليد السياسه والمغاليد العسكريه
على الطقس
طيب عندما نتحدث انه هذه هي النقطه
الرئيسيه بالنهايه القياده تحتاج الى
قاعده داعمه لها
الجيش السوداني لا زال يسيطر على مقر
القياده العامه ولكن هذا لا يمنع ان ننظر
بسيناريوهات اخرى ومنها اذا ما سيطر الدعم
السريع هل له تلك القاعده
الشعبيه او حتى العسكريه لكي يستطيع ان
يفرض سيطرته كيف يستطيع فرض السيطره بحال
سيطر على المقر
انا اعتقد انه يا ميسون من ناحيه فنيه
المساله هذه في باب الاستحاله صعبه جدا من
ناحيه فنيه خاصه انه القوات المسلحه كما
اسلفتوا قوله هي قوات قامت على اسس مهنيه
وعلى اسس علميه منذ عام 1925 ابانا
الاستعمار الانجليزي للسودان
وممارسه الكثير جدا من الحروب والمواجهات
العسكريه التي اعطتها خبره واسعه في
التعامل مع اي شكل من اشكال المواجهات
العسكريه لذلك انت الان
من ناحيه العدد ومن ناحيه العتاد ومن
ناحيه الامكانيات ومن نواحي الفنيه الاخرى
الادارات الاسلحه المختلفه تتفوق بشكل
كبير
جدا متابعه تطورات على الارض نعم
وسنتابع التطورات على الارض من الخرطوم
الكاتب الصحفي عادل سيد شكرا جزيلا لك ومن
الخرطوم ايضا ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن وهو نائب رئيس الغرفه
المركزيه للطوارئ طوارئ المستشفيات اهلا
بك دكتور محمد
اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديك هل يمكن لنا
احصاء حجم الضحايا الوضع في القطاع الصحي
بصره عامه تفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لكم تحيه
الصحه والعافيه
للمواطنين الكرام متمنين من الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان ينعمل الامن والسلامه السودان
الاحصاءات الاخيره
لحد الفجر اليوم
المسلسلات استقبلت عدد من الجرحى
1572 جريح منهم 96 وفاء هذه الاحصاء
تراكميه من يوم 19
725 لحد يوم 19 خلال
نتحدث عن يومين ولكن المحصله الكامله هل
لدينا ارقام
1572 مصاب
اعمال الحرب في العاصمه عدد الوفيات
الجاسم من مستشفيات على القطاعين القطاع
العام والقطاع الخاص هي 96 حاله من الجاي
متوفي من الشارع
العلاج داخل المستشفى
من المصابين عدد 288 عمليه جراحيه
226 منها في القطاع العام و62 عمليه
القطاع الخاص وعندما نتحدث عن
الاصابات نحن نتحدث عن اصابات
متوسطه ماذا هل لدينا معلومات هل هل
الاصابات خطره جدا في منها ولا لا
نعم ال 288 عمليه هي محصوره بانه عمليات
الخطره والعمليات
والعمليات المتوسطه اللي هي دي احتاجت الى
دخول غرفه عمليات
منهم 13 حاله في العنايه المكثفه على
الغطاءين العام والخاص نحن الغرفه
المركزيه معنيين بتغطيه الخدمات في 81
مستشفى خاص و53 مستشفى عامه للغرفه
المركزيه لكل
القطاع الصحي في ولايه الخرطوم وطبيعه
الخدمات التي توفرونها وهل هي متوفره اصلا
طيب الخدمات الصحيه من يوم 15 كانت نسبه
التغطيه في الخدمات ميه في الميه كالامات
العاديه حصل خروج بعض المستشفيات
من الخدمه يوم 17 لاسباب امنيه معظمها
لقطاع التيار الكهربائي لقطاع الامداد
المائي في بعض المستشفيات والان عاده
المستشفيات تدريجيا للخدمه مع عدم في في
وسط الخرطوم المستشفيات اللي فيها خطوره
امنيه
لمقدمه الخدمه وللمرضى اعدادهم بوسط
الخرطوم
العامه حول تسعه الان هي
لا تقدم الخدمه نسبه
العادات الامنيه حولها
والفرحه لهذه المسلسلات
وفيها مرضى ولكن هي مغلقه تقديم الخدمات
وعشرين مستشفى مستشفيات الخاصه لكن العدد
الان الذي يعمل في تقديم الخدمات 53
مستشفى منها سبعه مستشفيات لا تقدم الخدمه
باقي المستشفيات مقدمه للخدمه الغطاء
الخاص 81 مستشفى 20% عشرين مستشفى لا تقدم
الخدمه لاسباب امنيه ليس ليس الاسباب قطع
الامداد كما يعني
ومتى ما رابط راغب الاحوال او هي الاحوال
سترجع هذه المستشفيات لتقديم الخدمات حتى
تدريجيا الان الوضع مستقر الامداد مستقر
امداد الدم الاربع مراكز الدم متوفر عندنا
2,000 قزازه دم الان مفحوصه وخمسه الف كيس
دم من الامدادات
الاسعاف يعمل على قدم وساق كوادرنا
المسيفات تعمل بالحد الادنى من الكوادر
لتقديم الخدمات الطارئه بصوره اولويه
لجرحى الحرب
وعندما تقول ان
الاسعافى بمجهودات
لهذا
التيار الكهربائي لعدد كبير من المستشفيات
ثم حصل استقرار في الوقود وذلك بعد مناشده
القطاعات العامه والقطاعات الخاصه من هنا
بنقدمهم صوت شكر ولكن مناشدتنا عبر هذه
القناه انه السماح من الجهات المعنيه
السماح لحركه الاسعافات بحريه
وعبور الجسور بتقديم الخدمات الصحيه
للقطاعين المدني والعسكري ثم حمايه
المستشفيات الان التي لا تستطيع تقديم
الخدمات وهي في في مركز الخرطوم وفي مركز
الحدث محتاجين حمايه المستشفيات دي من اي
تفلتات
تكون من من الجهات المسلحه
لتوفير الامان
للكادر الشغاله للمريض حتى تكون التغطيه
بالخدمات الصحيه على المستوى الذي تغذي به
الخدمات لحفاظ ارواح المدنيين والعسكريين
ونتمنى ان تكون هذه المناشده قد وصلت
لاصحاب القرار من الخرطوم الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن نائب رئيس الغرفه
المركزيه للطوارئ طوارئ المستشفيات شكرا
جزيلا لك
والمزيد ايضا معنا من القاهره امان الطويل
مديره البرنامج الافريقي بمركز الاهرام
للدراسات اهلا بك دكتور اسمحيلي ان ابدا
بقراءه في المشهد الان اين وصلنا وكيف
تتوقعين ان يكون مصير الهدنه الثانيه التي
تم قبولها من قبل الدعم السريع في ظل هدنه
بداناها هشه وقد تم اختراقها اكثر من مره
اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الحقيقه
احنا الهدنه التالته مش التانيه
لان الهدنه الاولى لم يستجيب احد فيها
الهدنه التانيه تم اختراقها بسبب
وصول
عربات من الدعم السريع من مناطق الفججه
الخرطوم بحري على وجه الدقه وممارسهم
عمليات اطلاق نار ده طبقا للاصدقاء بالامس
الحقيقه انا مش متوقعه ان الهدنه التالته
يتم الالتزام بها لان انا شخصيا عندي
تقدير موقف ان يبدو ان قوات الدعم السريع
ليس لديها وسائل الاتصال بكل قواعدها
وبالتالي من الممكن تكرار مساله دخول
عربات تابعه للدعم السريع للاحياء دون
اتصال بقياده الدعم السريع ثم ان القبول
المتعجل من الجانب الدعم السريع لفكره
الهدنه يبدو ان دوافعها مرتبطه بتحسين او
وضعهم الميدانيه
ايذاء الجيش وربما هذا ما يفسر لنا انه
حتى الان لم نتلقى موافقه من الجيش على
الهدنه
وبالامس السؤال الذي سالته المصادر على
التابعه للقوات المسلحه
اجرائيا كيف تم تنفيذ الهدنه وهل تتضمن
مساله تحريك قوات او لا تتضمن هذه مسائل
على المستوى الفني يبدو انه من المطلوب
للاتفاق عليها حتى يمكن ان تملك مثل هذه
الهدنه او غيرها اليات تنفيذ فعليه طيب
وخلينا كوننا نتحدث عن الهدنه وعمليه نقل
جنود وغيرها خلينا نتحدث عن الجنود
المصريين الذي اعلن الدعم السريع انه تم
نقلهم من مروي الى الخرطوم كيف تفسرين هذه
العمليه ورغم التطمينات التي قدمت من انهم
بحاله صحيه جيده ويعاملون بطريقه جيده
ماذا تقرئين
انا الحقيقه اقرا انه يبدو ان الدعم
السريع كان لديها تقدير موقف
بوجود يعني باحتمال التدخل مصري عسكري
لصالح الجيش وربما هذا التقدير هو ما دفع
الدعم السريع في في المرحله الاولى من
الاشتباك او هي تسببت في الاشتباك في
الحقيقه ان تندفع نحو قاعده مرض
ومن هنا فان استمرار وجود افراد الكتيبه
المصريه في يد الدعم السريع سواء كانوا في
مراه او في الخرطوم او في غيرها نحن لا
نعلم مدى مصداقيه مثل هذه المعلومات في
محاوله لدرب طبقا لرؤيتهم او مزاعمهم تدخل
مصري محتمل رغم ان مصر قد اكدت انها لن
تتدخل وان هذا شان داخلي وفي تقدير مصري
ااا ان التدخل العسكري في مثل هذه الحالات
يؤدي الى توسيع الصراعات الى تحجمها وان
التداعيات
المتعلقه بتدخل مصري على المستوى السياسي
هي تعداعيات تكاليفها عاليه ولا داعي لها
كان معنا من القاهره امان الطويل مديره
البرنامج الافريقي بمركز الاهرام للدراسات
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
ومشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الساعه من
التغطيه ولكن مشاهدينا كما تعلمون التغطيه
مستمره حول التطورات في السودان اخر ما
وصلنا هو ان الدعم السريع اعلنت الموافقه
على هدنه جديده رغم ان الهدنه الاولى كانت
قد خرقت اكثر من مره هدنا هشه ولكن هناك
اعلانا عن هدنه جديده 24 ساعه من مساء هذا
اليوم حتى غدا الساعه السادسه شكرا
للمتابعه وننتقل على راس الساعه مع خالد
لتكمله هذه التغطيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات